up until today I hadn't played a single
round of advanced Warfare's multiplayer
but I have been powering my way through
EXO survival to unlock the zombie mode
to user that happens at the end and when
I fired up multiplayer afterwards lo and
behold I had unlocked a set of zombie
gear as well as a zombie skin for my
character it's a pretty cool little
addition even though it's only cosmetic
so I thought I'd share it with you guys
so we can all enjoy being undead
together unlock the skin
you must slog your way through the
somewhat underwhelming EXO survival mode
until you unlock the fourth tier of maps
after completing the 10th round on riot
in gear 4 you'll be faced with the wave
of zombies that teases the upcoming
zombie mode DLC after surviving a while
and making your way to the exit you'll
be shown a cutscene and should have
unlocked the zombie skin there was no
message telling me this afterwards so
just pop into multiplayer and behold the
fruits of your labor that's all there is
to it thanks for watching and I'll see
you on the battlefield